[Music]
hey so it's so great to be back in New
York City actually I grew up nearby here
and pleased to be co- speaking with
Jonathan thank you Stephen good to be
here and you know we're here to kind of
talk talk about leadership talk about
how you can actually do a bunch of the
things you've been hearing in practice
we're going to talk about strategy we're
going to talk about
technology but let's start with analysts
who who here trusts Gartner when Gartner
says something they're predicting the AI
wave they're predict okay nobody does
nobody no hands s up in the room for the
record but when they are predicting
failure and
catastrophes I I I try trust that right
so last year they predicted 30% of
generative AI projects are going to be
abandoned by the end of
2025 now anybody in the room this is a
really real honest check has anyone been
on a failing gen project okay now Brave
Sals amazing give give those guys around
that took a lot of
courage now to make them feel a little
better who who hasn't yet got to
production on their gen
app okay so the rest of the hands went
up right so this this is the
challenge so we all want to be
successful with Gen we all want to do
amazing things we're getting asked to do
amazing things but we we need to have
the right way of approaching this in our
organizations with leadership to sell
this internally to to build it on
Technologies which they can understand
and the the vision it's it's hard to get
a vision that's technically achievable
when the guy at the head of the table is
is this is this guy he's he's the
executive who's heard about J his kids
are using it for their School courses
and he's like oh yeah yeah just it
solves all the problems insert here
success I wanted in production in two
months now um I think the great thing
about having having jonath as my
co-presenter is that he's actually done
this in a big Life Sciences company and
he's had to navigate all of this um
leadership challenges organizational
challenges silos to
build a system which actually is
something we can take to production so
tell us a little bit more about that
Jonathan thanks Stephen now as I've been
introduced Jonathan low you may know me
as Jonathan when we're out in the
hallway or when I give you a bit more
information about my experience
launching gen based capabilities in
business you may think of me as Debbie
Downer AI is so exciting until the
singul
ity
so that's how I actually approached the
problem I'm about to explain to
you but it it actually worked so the
business case was technology transfer
which means in biofarma scaling up from
Lab bench think beers and human scale
drug development to Industrial scale
making a million doses a day and to get
from that lab bench level to multiple
factories around the world making lots
and lots of product very quickly takes
years because the industrial people that
build the factories and build the
equipment need to sift through hundreds
of thousands of documents and notes and
test outcomes that were created at the
science
level another challenge with doing that
is I'll go to a statistic in 2019
a study said that the average tenure of
manufacturing workers tenure being how
many years they had spent in their
companies was about 20 20 years of
average tenure what do you think the
average tenure is in manufacturing
companies
today the study said three years so
we've gone from 20 down to three and all
that
expertise has
has or will soon be retiring because the
boomers are growing
old so we really need generative AI we
need a machine to take a lot of the
intelligence that's captured in
documents or even inass it people's
heads and get it to the new people
showing up to do this technology
transfer so we take all these millions
of documents and we've loaded them into
a graph
now we haven't necessarily
loaded the document into the graph we've
loaded the chunks into the graph and one
of the things that we really liked using
the graph to accomplish was we
structured the chunks the document the
block the paragraph the line because we
wanted to understand when we searched
for those chunks with similarity search
which ones really returned the results
that people wanted the most we wanted to
really refine how we stored and managed
the chunks so at this at this point it
was it was a totally new space and
because we were able to structure in the
graph that level of chunking we were
able to eventually learn and get better
and better at how we chunked the
documents in the first
place yeah so I think what's really
amazing for me about this is um we were
talking about business challenges and
like like projects failing and in the
study that Gartner did the biggest
failure mode
was not having a business use case which
would actually solve real problems and
then be monetizable and um this is not
only like a great business use case but
it's also something which potentially is
Saving Lives because you're you're
getting life-saving drugs to folks
faster you're able to accomplish this
quicker
but the problem is always the humans in
the middle right so the teams you work
with probably have a little bit of gen
not invented here syndrome where you
come along with this great solution like
I'm going to use graph rag I'm going to
load all these documents into the my my
you know my my big um store and they're
like no no no I we've heard see this
research paper we watched this talk
there's some other platform we want to
use there's some other
framework um or maybe it's maybe it's
too expensive I mean compared to Classic
Computing and cloud computing gen
architectures have the potential will be
much more expensive if they're not well
architect
and in general are going to increase the
cost of the organization so how do you
convince people to go from a system
which is is working but not working well
enough to a much more expensive system
which is R&D investment Redevelopment to
go towards a gen architecture so what
are what are some of the challenges you
hit internally and how did you address
that
adviser great so for this
one it's more of an entrepreneurial use
case within a big organization I wonder
how many many of you have worked in
organizations with 50,000 or more
people a lot of hands going
up uh my current organization has over a
100,000 people I've also worked at IBM
deoe big organizations
and if you are like me in these
organizations you'll be that little red
guy going like this with the with the
light bulb over his head saying I have
an idea that might help the company
and I have a team of X number of data
scientists and developers and sres and
we can bring that value that capability
to the
company if you're like me if you're that
red
guy who's the first group of people on
this slide that you're most interested
in connecting with
for the top you go for the top you're
better than I am I I joined this whole
profession because I love building
applications that Delight the people
that use them so my instinct has always
been to go to the bottom first and say
to those users hey do you really want
this tool and what are those users going
to tell you they'll like your tool
if that's right what makes it good it
takes away boring stuff that they don't
want to
do but it can't just take away boring
stuff it also has to give them accurate
results it also has to work in a
performant way they can't push the
button go get coffee and come back and I
feel like that's the easy part right
more and more these days you can build
accurate fast applications quickly so
where's the real challenge so somebody
said you go to the top first what's the
likelihood in a company of 50,000 to
100,000 people that you're going to meet
the CEO if you're the guy with the idea
at the level four of the hierarchy the
likelihood is pretty small did anyone
here ever see the movie Dirty
Dancing Dirty
Dancing maybe do you remember the part
in Dirty Dancing when baby the lead
leading woman in the in the movie meets
Johnny the amazing dancer for the first
time and she she's uh she's unable to
speak she's so flustered and finally she
blurts out I carried a watermelon and
then off he goes and she goes I carried
a
watermelon two weeks ago I stepped into
the elevator on the seventh floor of of
the headquarters of of my company and
there was my CEO in the elevator and I
felt like baby and Dirty Dancing I
couldn't think of what to say I locked
up fortunately he's a good guy he broke
the ice just back from vacation rolling
up my sleeves can't wait to get to work
what are you up to and then thank God
ding we got to his floor the doors
opened and out he went and as he went
out the door I blurted out not I carried
a watermelon but I'm working with
llms off he went so when you're trying
to promote your work within a big
company like this it would help to know
what that executive is trying to
accomplish and the way that he gets to
that point is he talks to Consultants
who say let us tell you how to be a
leader in your industry
and not fall behind the competition so
an example of something that an
executive at that level might do is
create a purpose blueprint or something
like that name and the number one
message has to be a few words and convey
something that the whole company can
follow so an example of that might be
change a billion lives a year in life
sciences a big aspiration now why do you
have to care about that in the elevator
maybe you'll reference it I'm changing A
Billion Lives a with the most amazing AI
search engine Bing and off he goes but
that that message that he gives trickles
down to the next level the chief digital
officer the chief scientific officer the
chief Supply officer what do you think
they're going to
say they're going to try to take his
message and turn it into their specific
flavor so the digital officer will say I
want to lead the industry in Ai and the
scientific officer will say I want to
take on the world's biggest
diseases and the Supply officer will say
I want to accelerate Supply still very
high level and you probably won't meet
these people either who will you meet
though you'll meet their level twos and
their level threes and what are they
going to
say at this point they don't really say
taglines instead they say I want cost
savings I want cost
avoidance I want earlier realized
revenue or I want more balanced
headcount so when you're talking to
these people your slides have to have
numbers and times and your promises
about how your tool or your capability
or report or whatever is going to meet
meet those times and those
numbers now you may not get to meet them
either if your big company has a a form
of um a role called the client part
where your digital people talk to the
client partner and the client partner
talks to the business then that's the
other person you have to convince and
the problem with this is that the client
Partners tend to stay within their
particular departments there might be a
client partner who works exclusively in
R&D or one who works exclusively in
Supply what would they say sometimes
they don't say the same thing one of
them might say R&D already has five or
six or 10 search engines
why build
another or they might say search engine
is a great idea why don't you
incorporate that capability into every
tool in the supply organization so
either your scope goes to nothing or it
goes to everything and you need to be
able to negotiate and navigate
that are you done if you can satisfy all
those people and cross through all those
gauntlets well no because as you're
starting to build the vendor comes to
you and says why build in house when you
can buy our tools and they've been
talking to the chief digital officer
about build versus buy and which one is
more economically realistic and
appropriate well maybe you get through
that and then you're done
right who else would possibly stand in
the way of your incredible AI Search
tool Friendly Fire is the answer your
own colleagues either level above or at
the same level may say dude I was here
first AI search is my turf or they might
just say hey that client partner over in
Supply is right can you please integrate
with the stuff I've built so I guess my
message is we've heard a lot of talks
about failure and Challenge and Gartner
not liking this it's an incredible time
to be in this in this amazing industry
in this amazing change in both for me
life sciences and more generally for the
information technology
industry and I love that we're hearing
all this concern about failure because
it just means we're at the beginning of
a really exciting time but as
representatives of that my advice to you
is know your audience personalize for
all of them and get your human wetwear
chatbot speaking the right language at
the right
level now that's that's amazing um we
chatted out a bunch of challenges right
so we've chatted about getting a good
business use case that can actually
provide values the organization how to
navigate like like peoples and and
different failure modes um within the
organization where the organization has
a huge quantity of people who can be
your allies or can work against you
depending upon how you work with them
but it's also a technology problem you
have to have the right technology to
solve your use case now one of the the
biggest challenges I think a lot of us
who have been building Rag and
Enterprise applications has been the LMS
themselves fighting us with with
hallucinations this is getting better
with newer models um it's getting easier
to feed the right sort of information in
with Vector databases but I think that
you've chosen a rather unique approach
using graph databases why did why did
you choose to use a graph database for
your implementation at
fiser well um
there are a lot of things that graphs
aren't good at things like genealogic
sequences of recipes or social networks
or hierarchies or time series and all of
those applications were prevalent
opportunities within fizer so that was
the that was the original impetus for
using a graph but I also discovered that
the more data we Consolidated in the
graph the faster my data scientists and
engineers and developers and SRE were
able to understand the data landscape
what used to take 3 months to
consolidate understand clean up took
three weeks or less for for a new
project so I know the reason a lot of
people take on graph is because
traversal becomes so much easier in
terms of data search and uh and and
performance gets better but I found that
team performance also took a really big
Boost from using that Tech cool and for
folks who aren't familiar with with
knowledge graphs and LMS or or graph rag
um this isn't a new idea although I I
would put you guys on the early adopter
where you're actually in production now
with something that uses this but U
Microsoft kind of wrote the seminal
paper on graph Rag and used it basically
taking existing documents llms to chunk
it into a graph and then showed Superior
results coming out of it it on the
spectrum of Technologies using LMS
directly you can get good results but it
lacks that context it lacks that
Enterprise knowledge using a vector
database or or Baseline rag you you can
get better results where now it's
actually pulling in organizational
knowledge but the answers tend to be a
little bit generic there's a lot of
hallucinations um graph rag kind of
pulls us to the end of the spectrum
where now you're you're getting answers
from that that Knowledge Graph you built
you can evolve over time and much more
precise answers which actually get to
the heart of of real problems and in
life sciences and Manufacturing and
business critical Industries where you
can't afford to be
wrong and also where in in industries
that are complicated if there are a lot
of connections that might not appear in
a relational database because no one
bothered to make the joins permanent
whereas in a graph those joins are there
to begin with so if you search for one
thing suddenly the neighborhood of
related stuff becomes available to you
to share with an llm for better
contextual
knowledge yeah and you know I think just
if folks are implementing this or folks
are thinking about how to how to think
about architectures for graph rag um
this is a really simple way of thinking
about it so basically what you're doing
is you're taking your gen
application and you're doing both a
vector and a Knowledge Graph
representation of the data so you're
both asking the vector for the answer
you're getting relationally close nodes
from the graph database where you're
getting additional context and passing
that in the LM and then this gives you
more contextually relevant results
coming out of your your expert system so
I think this is a great way to use a
Knowledge Graph either that you built up
over time or that you have the LM
construct to kind of get those Superior
results where you could do better
governance you can put controls and
properties on the graph nodes to control
who has access to the
information you can get better
explainability now because when you're
getting an answer from the LM you're no
longer looking at statistical
probabilities in the vector space you're
actually looking at graphs and nodes and
edges which we can reason about and we
can start to understand the relationship
between understand like what what things
are related to manufacturing which
things are unrelated to that they're
just you know general
terms and for the right
application maybe we're saving lives
getting drugs to people more quickly and
using gen for a good cause so thanks so
much for joining us for our presentation
at AI engineering Summit and um
appreciate everybody thank you
[Music]